- Hi, everyone, welcome
to this afternoon's
Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities event,
our distinguished speaker series
and we have a very exciting speaker today.
We have the mathematician
and author Jordan Ellenberg
and his talk title is
"I prove a theorem and the house
expands, geometry and poetry."
But before I introduce our
speaker for this afternoon,
I would first like to thank
Richard and Barbara Franke
for their generosity
in funding and supporting
the Franke program
and many other activities that
cross disciplinary boundaries
and give opportunities
for scholars young and old
to dare to try research projects
that are not confined
to single disciplines.
And I also want to remind
all of you assembled
that we are recording this event
and therefore all participants
must mute their videos.
And as is customary for our
events if you have a question,
please go ahead and put it in the chat.
And our, we tend to have
a Q&A offer of a talk
unless Dr. Camp and I are
keeping track of the chat.
So if it's a burning question,
we'll go ahead and ask it right away,
if not, we will bank
it for the Q&A session.
So it is my absolute
delight today to introduce
our wonderful speaker Jordan.
Professor Jordan Ellenberg
grew up in Potomac in Maryland,
and it turns out that
math might be in his genes
because his parents
are both statisticians.
He excelled in mathematics
from a very young age
and competed for the U.S.
representing the United States
in the International Mathematics
Olympiad three times,
winning two gold medals and a silver.
This I should point out is
absolutely no mean achievement
to get two golds and silver.
That is super impressive Jordan.
He went to college at Harvard,
sadly you know, the other
place over there and attained
a master's degree in fiction
writing from Johns Hopkins.
And then he returned
back to Harvard for a PhD in mathematics.
After graduate school,
he did a brief stint as
a postdoc at Princeton
and in 2004, he joined
the faculty of the University
of Wisconsin at Madison,
where he's now
the John D MacArthur
professor of mathematics,
His research centers on
fields of number theory
and algebra geometry you know,
the portions of mathematics
that address very fundamental questions
about the nature of equations
and their solutions in whole numbers.
Jordan's research
has uncovered new and
unexpected connections
between these subjects
and algebraic topology,
the study of abstract
higher dimensional shapes
and the relationships between them.
Ellenberg was a plenary speaker
at the 2013 joint mathematics meeting
one of the largest mathematics
conferences in the world.
And he has lectured about his research
in multiple countries and multiple venues.
He has a ton of awards and honors
and recognition because I'm
dying to hear him speak,
I'm gonna give you a
very abbreviated version.
He was awarded an NSF career grant
and Alfred P.Sloan Foundation Fellowship,
he was a fellow is a fellow
of the American Mathematical Society
and a Guggenheim fellow
and Assignments fellow.
So, Jordan has been writing
for a general audience
about mathematics for more than 15 years
and his work has appeared in many of the
most industrious outlets
in New York times,
Wall Street Journal, Washington
Post Wire, Boston globe
and he is the author of Do
The Math column in Slate.
His novel Grasshopper King
was a finalist for the 2004
New York Public Library
Young Lions Fiction Award.
His 2014 book, so this is not
today he will be talking to
us about his latest book,
but as you see, it's not his first book.
He's had many wonderful books before,
and I was first introduced to his writing
when I read his 2014
book, How Not To Be Wrong
and that was a New York Times bestseller
and a Sunday Times London bestseller.
He lives in Madison, Wisconsin,
and he's speaking to
us from his home today.
And in particular,
I just wanna point out if
you haven't already bought it
Jordan's latest book is called SHAPE,
the hidden geometry of
information, biology, strategy,
democracy, and just about everything else.
It's actually there in the title
everything else is in the title.
So Jordan, without further ado
I am so delighted you're
here with us today
I wish it could have been in person,
but we can't wait to hear from you.
Thank you so much for coming.
- Well, thank you so much Priya
and thanks to the Franke's
for making this talk possible.
I wrote a book about geometry
and this is a picture
this is the front of
piece of the book actually
it's sort of a map of the whole book
and if I were giving
a talk about the book,
I would just have to
cover all of these topics
in 45 minutes, which would
be pretty hard to do.
But maybe let me sort of zero
in on one particular aspect,
which is that if you look sort of
very near the center of the
map, we see a box called poetry.
And I did not expect
that when I was writing
a book about geometry,
I was gonna find myself talking
about poetry so very much
and in so many different contexts.
And so I thought for this
audience and for this center,
it seemed the perfect time to
sort of spend a little time
just talking about where
those connections come from
and what they seem to
mean to the geometers
and the poets who participated in them.
And I guess if you guys have questions
about any of the other things on this map
and what they have to do
with poetry or geometry
feel free to pipe in some of them are,
some of these are names
of people who are gonna
show up in this talk
and others are not,
'cause we only have a limited
amount of time together.
Okay so, if you think
about geometry and poetry
probably there's like one number one line
that you have heard
and it's a line I think
we don't know the source of this line,
like know the line "Euclid
alone has looked on beauty bare"
and it's from a sonnet by Edna St. Vincent Millay,
who you see in this picture here.
But this is not really
what I'm gonna talk about.
In some sense,
I wanna sort of set this
up as a little bit of
something I wanna gesture
the antithesis to.
Because malaise Euclid presented here
is this kind of singular on earthly figure
who kind of gets blasted
with enlightenment
by a shaft of insight on what Millay calls
"a holy terrible day."
And in this poem, it's kind of like
there's Euclid, he's alone, he's Euclid
the rest of us or the rest of us.
Like maybe if we're lucky,
we kind of get to hear beauty's footsteps
wandering way down a hallway
or something like that.
And that is not really
geometry as I see it
and I think it's not really
true to the history of geometry
that I wanna talk about today.
I mean, look, don't get me wrong
I am a mathematician, that's my job
I get a lot of benefit from geometry
this kind of mystique that
it has for a lot of people.
It feels good when people
think that the work you do
must be like mysterious, and eternal,
and elevated above the common plane.
Like people, like how
was your day at work?
And you're like, oh, you
know boring and terrible
the usual stuff like that, okay.
So that benefits us to an extent,
but it's not really true to our practice
or the way we see what we do.
So we're just gonna kind
of take a tour through
some other views and how
they relate to this one.
So let me just start, with
this very famous dinner party
that takes place in the 19th century,
and two of the guests
are Wordsworth and Keats
who you see here.
And Keats at this party is
kind of trolling Wordsworth
he's by insulting Isaac Newton,
who was a favorite of Wordsworth saying,
Newton had destroyed all
the poetry of the rainbow
by reducing it to prismatic
colors and then he'd like
even this famous toast
confusion to mathematics
and this sort of party is divided
between the people who wanna
toast confused mathematics,
the people who don't feel
comfortable with that,
like Wordsworth.
Later, maybe I'll even read
a little bit of Keats here
because he later writes
a philosophy will clip an Angel's wings,
conquer mysteries by rule
in line there's the geometry
empty the haunted air and no
mud mine, unweave a rainbow.
So unweaving the rainbow
as you see here depicted by Pink Floyd
on their cover of Dark Side
of the Moon that's almost,
that's sort of since then
has become like a metaphor
for the mean thing that geometry
does to beauty to nature.
It dissolves it, it breaks
it down to something
that is much less interesting,
namely mathematics.
Okay, this was not Wordsworth view.
Wordsworth by contrast
saw Newton as a kind
of transcendent figure
exactly the kind that
romantic poetry should admire.
He famously called Newton,
I guess it's not like a 100%
who's he's referring to,
but it is steady or frightening
a mind forever voyaging
through strange seas
of thought alone.
That's a little bit like
notice that alone, right?
That echoes what Millay
said, kind of the same vibe.
Similarly, that's from the preludes
and let me give you something
else from the preludes.
Oh, I don't know why I have a
random cursor stuck in there
sorry. that's a screenshot thing.
That the cursor is not
equally it's not Wordsworth,
but the words are
"Mighty is the charm
of those abstractions."
Those abstractions means that
the abstractions of geometry
to a mind beset with images
and haunted by itself.
You know, I never noticed
until this second,
because I don't usually
use that Keats quote.
That Keats says, "Empty the haunted air."
So words within Keats
are both, (indistinct) geometry
as an antidote to haunting
I should make a note for myself
'cause I haven't seen
that connection before.
But for Keats that's good,
'cause haunting is like the
presence of like true spirits
that are interesting and math is boring.
Wordsworth thinks it's good
to be charmed and to kind
of heal your hauntedness.
But he's ready, this is
actually kind of crazy,
he's writing, this is part
of him telling a story
it's kind of a crazy story of
a guy who's shipwreck on a desert island
and he has nothing with
him, but Euclid's element.
This kind of famous book of Euclid's
that lays out the basics of geometry
and he's like completely
depressed, and alone and hungry
and in Wordsworth's poem,
he kind of suits himself.
This is the moment at which he like
his constellation is
the presence of Euclid,
the presence of geometry
enables him to kind of
get his mind away from
like all his regrets.
I know that's kind of a weird story
and you're like, why would,
that seems like a little
bit of a rickety story
for Wordsworth to make up
and put in his preludes
and one thing that's interesting about it
is that it's basically true.
He took it from the memoirs
of a different Newton,
John Newton who, I mean,
it's a whole story but
he really was shipwrecked
he really did have Euclid with him.
And he's not so famous for this
he's famous because he then
goes back to England and gets religion
and he is the author of
the hymn Amazing Grace.
So interesting story.
But so this is Wordsworth's view,
a much more positive view
of what geometry can do
and the way he felt about geometry,
he also felt about geometers.
So one interesting moment is that
he becomes very good friends
with William Rowan Hamilton,
I don't know if that's a name
that everybody here knows,
but Hamilton is an
absolutely central figure
in the development of 19th
century, algebra and geometry,
sort of a child prodigy.
And when they meet it's this kind of
very classic May, December
intellectual romance
where Hamilton is I think 22 or 23,
but he's already a professor
of astronomy of mathematics
in Dublin.
And the two of them absolutely
can not get enough of each other
they like go on long walks
and talk about everything.
Part of that, is because Hamilton himself
while being famous
today as a mathematician
also wanted to be a poet, he
really wanted to be a poet
and wrote poetry his whole life.
He was always very ambivalent about it,
feeling like did he really deserve it.
So at one point he renounces poetry
and of course he renounced
his poetry by writing a poem
about his pronunciation of
poetry called To Poetry.
And there's kind of a cycle
he renounced his poetry,
then he's like, I can't do it
I gotta go back writing poems.
Then he, he actually
renounced poetry again
and wrote a second poem called To Poetry,
which I haven't reproduced here
and he's constantly sending
all this stuff to Wordsworth.
So after he sends his
second renunciation poem
to Wordsworth, he really
wants Wordsworth's approval
and Wordsworth, he's really nice about it.
He, it's sort of one of the great, gentle,
kind let downs in early history.
Wordsworth writes a long
letter to Hamilton saying like,
I really like your poems,
they're really good
I wish I could encourage
you to keep writing them
but the loss to science
would just be too great.
I couldn't allow myself to be responsible
for the geometry and the
mathematics and the astronomy
that wouldn't happen if I encouraged you
to keep writing poems.
So that's how Wordsworth
kind of handled this
rather delicate social
situation with his young friend.
So where are we?
I guess what we've seen
is that what poets
traditionally think geometry is
at least poets of Wordsworth Spain
or Millay for that matter,
poets were sympathetic to jump at all.
They don't think it's just
some completely boring BS,
that's meant to sort of drain
the world of its spirit,
which is what keeps thought.
What they think is that
it's some means of content
with a transcendent,
some means of contact
with something that is
the same kind of thing
that romantic poetry wanted
to be in con, you could
call it the divine,
you could call it the transcendent,
something beyond ordinary
human experience.
So what does geometers
typically think poetry is?
We should look at the other side of it.
That's a little complicated.
We talked about Hamilton,
who I think has a pretty
mainstream relationship with Cody.
But I also wanna talk about
James Joseph Sylvester,
who we see here.
This is another
big time 19th century
British mathematician.
Famous by the way,
to everyone who knew him
for having a gigantic head
that's not just the picture like that's,
he was a guy who was well-known
by everyone in the community
for having a huge head.
I said he was a mathematician,
but he was almost the first
American mathematician.
I maybe I just, I can't
not tell this story.
I mean, so he came to the
University of Virginia in 1844,
at a time when there was essentially
no research map enterprise
in the United States at all.
So this was a very bold
and forward looking move
by the University of Virginia to bring in
a really, really strong
young mathematician
from Europe to kind of start
a community from scratch.
And it did not end well.
And you know, if you
have anybody in your life
who likes to complain about how entitled
American college students are these days.
Maybe you are such a person,
or maybe you just have such
people on your social media feed
or whatever.
I just really wanna encourage you
in the strongest possible terms
to read about what American
college students were like
in the early 19th century.
Because it will make you feel
like we now live in a paradise.
And part of the reason I mentioned this is
I got to tell a good Yale
story so in Yale in 1830.
44 students,
including the son of a sitting
vice-president John Calhoun
were expelled after they refused
to take a final exam in
geometry that had been changed
by the last minute from
open book to closed books.
And this was known at Yale
for decades afterwards as
the conic sections rebellion.
Okay, so the University of Virginia
was not very different from
Yale at this point in time.
It was very aristocratic and
what was appealing perhaps
to the faculty the idea of this
distinguished senior scholar
was not appealing to the students at all.
Sylvester expected obedience,
he expected attention to lessons,
he did not treat this sort of aristocratic
mostly Southern students
at University of Virginia
with the deference that they expected.
And the semester ended with Sylvester
getting into a physical
fractious with an undergraduate
thinking that he had
killed the undergraduate.
He fled United States
and went back to England
and built his career there
and did eventually come back to the U.S.
to teach Johns Hopkins in 1870s.
But essentially that was
the cause of essentially a 30 year delay
in the founding of American mathematics.
Okay, but really I
mean, it's a good story,
but really I wanna talk
about Sylvester and poetry.
He said at the beginning
of a speech one time,
an eloquent mathematician
must from the nature of beings
ever remain as rare
phenomenon as a talking fish.
It's a great line,
but of course it's one of
those self-deprecating things
that you only say,
if you actually think that
you are the exception.
Right, which is definitely
what Sylvester thought
Sylvester's definitely was
rather proud of his verbal skill.
And in fact, one thing he's known for
is he coined a lot of mathematical
terms that we use today.
You know, invariant, discriminant
probably the most famous one is matrix.
If you've ever taken linear
algebra or even algebra two
in high school or like
seeing action movies,
like it's a word you know,
the matrix that is a coinage
of Sylvester's.
And indeed like Hamilton,
Sylvester was a poet.
He wrote what I think must be
the only sonnet ever addressed
to an algebraic expression,
this one to a missing member
of a family group of terms
and an algebraic formula,
so I see some mathematicians in the room
so I think this is a poem
addressed to them on monomial.
I'm not gonna read this one in full,
but you can like look at it
and sort of get its vibe.
Maybe one thing I wanna say about him
is that even though he is a geometer,
he has a rather different view of geometry
than (indistinct) and Vincent Millay.
In fact, in a stance you
might not expect them
at petition to have,
he doesn't even really
care for Euclid himself.
Here's what he says,
the early study of Euclid
made me a hater of geometry.
Which I hope I may plead my excuse,
if I have shocked the
opinions of any in this room,
he was definitely like
the 19th century version
of these people.
Unpopular opinion that
was definitely his thought
anyway sorry, I'll continue this boat.
If I have shocked the
opinions of any in this room
and I know there are
some who ranked Euclid
a second and sacredness
to the Bible alone,
and that's one of the advanced outposts
of the British constitution.
Okay, so what he's complaining about
is that he feels that
people are too attached
to like the perfect Euclid, set in stone
1,000 or more years ago.
He wants a geometry that is
more tied to real things,
more tied to the physical world
and he complains about
how British education
is completely far behind them.
He writes, it is this living
emphasis in the subject
which is so wanting our traditional
and medieval modes of teaching
he's talking about Britain.
In France, Germany and Italy,
everywhere where I have
been on the continent
mind acts direct on
mind in a manner unknown
the frozen formality of
our academic institutions.
So, Sylvester is a person
who does not want geometry
to be up there far away
he wants to be down here with us,
dealing with physics,
dealing with astronomy,
dealing with the world that we observe
with our sensory apparatus.
I would say it goes to far
as geometry is of interest
only in so far as a captures
reality and provides insight.
And as for poetry,
he sees it as something
which like physics has laws
that can be divined by
reflection and experimentation,
and that it's worth doing this
that you actually learn
something about it and understand
it better by understanding
its underlying laws.
So look, I'm not gonna
say that Sylvester's view
has really taken hold as a
mode of literary criticism.
But he did sort of sit down
and write an entire book
The laws of verse,
otherwise known as
principles of versification.
And delivered it as his opening
address when he was named
the president of the
mathematical society of Britain.
So, this was something
he really cared about
and he thought that geometric
mathematical techniques
really could be brought to bare,
on the study of literature.
And this is kind of a running
theme for better and worse
I'll show you an example of both.
So let's move to the 20th century,
the beginning of the 20th century.
And Andrey Markov, who was
a Russian mathematician,
who is one of the founders
of probability theory.
And in particular,
the creator of what is now
called the Markov chain
and you know, in a different kind of talk.
Well, I could give I could,
and in fact often do give a whole hour
on the origin of the Markov
chain and the incredible bouquet
of applications it has in
the contemporary world.
I'm just gonna say a tiny bit about it
what you are looking at
is Markov's analysis.
So he mentioned by the way,
I should say this to when
a theological argument
with another mathematician
about the nature of freewill,
a very strange story that I
thought had to be apocryphal,
and I researched it for the
book and it's completely true.
But later he's applying it
to, the poem Eugene Onegin
which this is not the
way it's usually typeset,
but he was writing its letters one by one
in a series of grids that's
what the picture you see here.
And let me just briefly say,
what kind of analysis Markov does.
How does he make a Markov
chain out of this poem?
He says, let me throw out
everything in this poem
except for the pattern
of consonants and vowels
and what he says that you can
sort of like model this poem,
please don't be mad at poets
I'm gonna I'm not saying
this is what the poem is
and neither is Markov but
I'll explain what I'm doing.
He observed by counting a
lot of letters and grids
like I showed you on the last slide,
that when you had a consonant, the next,
the next letter was a
vowel 66.3% of the time.
In other words,
most of the time a consonant
was followed by a vowel
and not by another consonant
that happened only about
a third of the time.
Whereas a vowel was even more
rarely followed by a vowel
and was much more commonly
followed by a consonant.
So you can imagine
a kind of imitation
Eugene Onegin generator
that maybe you start with some consonant
and then you say, okay,
I'm just gonna out random
two thirds of the time, pick a vowel
and one third of the
time pick a consonant.
And then if I'm at a
vowel 87.2% of the time,
pick a consonant and 12.8%
of the time, pick a vowel
and just let that run
just keep on doing that for a long time.
And then I'll get something
that I might call an imitation
of this famous poem by Pushkin.
Okay, that would be like a really,
really bad imitation, right?
This seems like an
incredibly impoverished view
of what this poem could be,
but let me make the point that
even this incredibly minimal
amount of information
is enough for instance, to
distinguish two different poets.
So this is what Markov does in his paper
the top diagram is the
diagram I just showed you
and the second one is a
diagram, produced from a novel
by a I think now mostly
forgotten Russian novelist
named (indistinct).
And even this very meager model is enough
to tell the difference between
these two Russian writers.
So, as I said, I'm not
gonna tell the entire story
of Markov chain but I'll just
comment that in modern usage,
you can use models which
are much more sophisticated
than this, but still much
less sophisticated than
our actual like human linguistic faculties
to do a much better although
far from perfect job
of imitating text, mechanical production
of something that kind of
imitates english language.
If you've heard of (indistinct) three,
it's a very interesting
contemporary example
of a machine like this.
But here's a simpler one,
what I did is just train the Markov chain
to imitate baby names,
just to kind of show you
what kind of information
can be retained by these kind
of rather simple geometric
models of language production.
You see three lists of
made up names here, right?
My computer made, one of them
I trained it to imitate baby
names from babies born in 1917.
Another one I trained on baby
names for babies born in 1971,
which is the year I was born.
And another one I trained on baby names
for babies born in 2017.
And I'll bet, everybody in the audience
can tell which list is which,
which is the list that
imitates 2017 names,
which is the list that imitates 1917 names
and which is the list that
imitates a 1971 names.
So it's kind of cool, I mean
it because it's clearly,
some of these are names
that are actual real names,
some of them are names
that sound plausible,
that sound terrible.
So it's certainly not doing
the same thing humans do
when we make up names for our children
and yet it is capturing some
interesting features of style
in this purely mathematical way.
So I'm not gonna tell you the answers
but I bet you all know,
but if people are not sure we
can talk about it at the end.
So, and this by the way, this notion,
I truly do not feel Keats might have
but I do not feel that this
is an anti-literary thing
to think about.
By con on the contrary,
I think there is actually
like a pretty long tradition
of mechanical production
of language, like writing,
like the data poets used to do.
In literature not as a way
to produce finished product,
but as a way to kind of
energize creativity as a way
to understand something about
our unconscious processes
of language production.
I do wanna give one
cautionary tale I said,
for better or for worse,
somebody I wrote about in my
last book How Not Be Wrong
was B.F.Skinner and his
spring of Shakespeare.
So I quote this only in
order to object to it.
But you know, he wrote a
famous paper where he's like,
people say Shakespeare alliterates,
but I studied the
mathematical, mathematically
and I say, Shakespeare did not alliterate.
So he was doing, I think
what should as my petition
should refrain from doing.
We're here I mean just like
mathematical physicists
should refrain from telling
the universe what to do.
We're here to understand
things about literature,
not to deny things about literature
that writers already understand.
B.F.Skinner writes,
"In spite of the seeming
richness of liberation
in the sonnets and seeming richness,
what such power, right?"
Blah, blah, blah.
"So far, is this aspect
of poetry is concerned
Shakespeare might as
well have drawn his words
out of the hat."
And I have to say, when I
looked into this though,
I learned something interesting.
Skinner, like Sylvester, like Hamilton
wanted to be a writer
that's what he wanted
to do when he was young.
He wanted to be a novelist actually
he didn't wanna write poems,
but he, he went to Bread Loaf,
he got a nice letter from Robert Frost,
like this was his thing and
then he just didn't succeed
he tried and tried to write, he didn't,
he couldn't really finish stuff.
And he had a lifelong
grudge against literature
and he wrote in his journals,
literature must be destroyed
He was very angry.
So, I mean, is this funny
that this sort of apostle's
this great apostle of rationalism,
you see sort of his like childhood anger
kind of like leaking out into
his hostility to Shakespeare.
Okay, we're gonna be together,
at least me talking for
about 10 more minutes,
and then I'm gonna take questions.
So let me finish off trying to bring us,
we're still like in the middle
of the 20th century here.
So let me bring us to the
present and an actual alive poet
there's will be at least one
at any point we talk, right?
And this is Rita Dove,
who is a former poet Laureate
of the United States,
who is now as it happens,
a professor at the University of Virginia,
where Sylvester beat up a
student with a sword cane
about 150 years ago.
And I'm gonna show you two of her poems.
And actually, because we have time,
I think I'll read them
'cause they're great poems.
And I did get here fast enough to do it.
So here's, you know,
most contemporary poets
don't even write one poem, one math poem.
Dove wrote two, at least
these are the two that I know.
So I'm gonna read them to you.
So the first one's called "Flash Cards".
In math I was the whiz kid
keeper of oranges and apples.
What you don't understand
master, my father said
the faster I answered
the faster they came.
I could see one bud on
the teacher's geranium.
One clear beast buttering at the wet pane.
The tulip tree always
dragged after heavy rain.
So I tucked my head as
my boots slapped home.
My father put up his feet after work
and relaxed with a highball
and the life of Lincoln
after supper we drilled and I
climbed the dark before sleep
before a thin voice hissed
numbers as I spun on a wheel,
I had to guess 10, I
kept saying I'm only 10.
Okay, this is a view of math, right?
A very well depicted childhood story.
Let me read another poem of hers,
which is called "Geometry."
Geometry.
I prove a theorem and the house expands
the windows jerk free to
hover near the ceiling.
The ceiling floats away with a sigh.
As the walls clear themselves
of everything but transparency,
the scent of carnations leaves with them.
I'm out in the open and above
the windows have hinged into butterflies,
sunlight glinting where
they've intersected.
They are going to some
point true and unproven.
Okay, so two math poems.
I'm gonna leave this up for a minute.
But extremely different
in their tone, right?
Poems talking some sense
about the same thing,
a child learning mathematics,
but they could not be more different.
This second poem, I think is
in some ways, very close to Wordsworth
what Wordsworth, when he wrote
Mighty Is The Charm, right?
There's sort of something about the
mentally healing aspect
of studying geometry.
But there is something more here, I think,
than what Wordsworth was writing about.
Maybe partly because Wordsworth really
wasn't interested in
mathematics as a child.
He was an indifferent student.
He sort of was interested
in the idea of it
and people like Hamilton attracted him.
Dove by contrast really was
very strong in math as a child
and is writing from her own experience.
And I think she has sort
of more of a feeling
for what it's actually,
I think there's something really more here
in the distinction between the poems.
Again, I could do a whole
hour and I'm at pedagogy
I'm not going to.
but this distinction between memorization,
which is what takes
place in the first poem
and understanding,
which just takes place
in the second, right?
In the first poem,
it doesn't really seem like
her father is asking her
to understand something about arithmetic.
He's drilling her.
In the second poem, this
thing I just noticed actually,
I heard this poem about 100 times by now,
but like there is no authority
figure in this poem, right?
In real life, there would presumably
be a teacher in the
room where this happens.
Well, maybe she's in
school, maybe he's at home.
But if she's at home, the
father is not in the poem.
If she's at school, the teacher
is not in the poem, right?
It's just her, just her and the geometry.
And this is something about
what makes geometry special
that makes it jump out
from everything else
in the young student curriculum
that you can make knowledge by yourself.
You don't need a parent
or a teacher to tell you,
you don't need to rely
on a book that tells you
what happened long before you were alive.
You can start from the
basic rules and construct
your own knowledge, independent
of any authority figure
to the point that as in this poem,
the authority figures completely banishes.
And this is, this feature
of geometry is why
geometry has often been seen as a threat
to the established order of things.
I didn't put this in my notes,
but it just occurs to be
mentioned that you know
Newton, we talked about who
likes him, who hates him.
He was certainly seen as a threat
by religious establishment
and there was like,
he adored his defenders,
wrote books with titles
like Geometry has no
friends to infidelity.
You don't write that book
unless somebody's saying
the opposite, right?
So this idea of geometry
as a kind of liberation
that I think is very contemporary
I don't think it's really
there in the 19th century
those we talked about.
Except maybe in one place,
so sorry for the bad
reproduction of this picture.
But this is a picture from
a book called Flatland
I don't know if you guys have read it.
We're back in the 19th
century in England now
it's a book by Edwin Abbott,
whose middle name was also
Abbott added by the way,
Edwin Abbott Abbott.
And let me just briefly tell
you what the story is about
and if you haven't read
it, it's kind of charming
I recommend it.
The book is called Flatland
because it takes place in
a two dimensional world
and the main character is a Square.
Everyone in this world is
a two dimensional figure
(indistinct) determined
by how many sides you have
with, you know, triangles
as the working class,
square it's a little better,
hexagons very fancy,
circles are like the best.
And one day the square
was kind of in this house
when a circle, a very small
circle appears in his house.
He's like, oh my God there's like
some like baby aristocrat
here, like what's going on?
And then something very strange happens.
The circle starts
getting bigger and bigger
going before his eyes
and the square is like,
what uncanny nonsense is this,
like, this makes no sense
this cannot be happening.
And of course, well you
can figure what's happening
because I showed you a picture of it.
He is being visited by a being
from the three-dimensional
world, a sphere.
And as the sphere starts to enter,
his flat land moves more fully into it
and finally immerses itself
totally in the squares,
two dimensional world so that the plane
is cutting the sphere at it's a crater.
It appears to the square
to get bigger and bigger
that's the only way he can interpret
this three-dimensional motion.
And so then what follows,
this very long argument
where the sphere is trying
to explain to the square,
what the third dimension is
and square just keeps on being
like, but it makes no sense
I mean, you're saying it,
but you're talking about
something that doesn't exist.
And finally, the sphere is
able to convince the square.
The sphere says in my world,
there's a being that's a lot
like you called the cube.
It's just like you
except three-dimensional.
And he's able to sort of help
the square to reason about
the fact that if there
were a being like him,
but three-dimensional,
it would have to have
eight vertices and 12 edges
and six faces each of which
was the square like him.
And the square, just purely
through reason, you know,
they go back and forth a bit
is able to grasp this sort of,
actually I told this story
in a bit in the wrong order,
I would love it if it was just purely
an exercise of reasoning.
But in fact, what happens is
the sphere grabs the square
and pulls him out of his world
so that he can see his world from above.
And then the square really believes it,
the square is like whereas like okay,
I've been to the third
dimension, I can see it.
But here's what happens next
is sort of an ironic moment.
We can talk about a whole thing about like
the religious imagery here,
but I think I won't do it.
The square having had this revelation,
having been supplied this
revelation by the sphere
is very excited and it's like, now get it,
now at last I understand what
you were trying to tell me.
Now I understand why a
three-dimensional version of me
would have to have these
properties, even though I don't
really have the sensory
apparatus to perceive it
I can figure it out by reason.
And what's more now I understand
what the four dimensional
version of me would be like.
That it would have faces
for themselves cubes
and it would have like edges
and it would have 16 vertices,
like now I understand everything.
And the sphere is like, what
the hell are you talking about?
There's no fourth dimension,
like that's ridiculous
like 3D is how many dimensions there are
were you not listening to anything I said?
So it's this, it's this
rather arch moment,
sorry for the spoilers,
but this book is from 1881,
where even the sphere is sort of like
locked into its prison,
the perception and the,
and then the square is able to go past.
But again, it's because
of the power of geometry
and because of the power
of mathematical reason,
if the square is able to
break free from this prison
of what it is able to see.
Deliberate itself from the
authorities of its own world.
So back to the present,
what do we think geometry is now
what I'm gonna close,
because we're here at this kind of nexus
of science and humanities
is I wanna emphasize
what I think is really
most present in Dove
out of all that we've talked about.
The geometry, like all of mathematics
is fundamentally a human activity.
It's something humans
do for human purposes.
And so I, you know, what
I like to say is that math
is made of people.
So as much as there's an aspect of it,
that we may feel is like beyond
humanity, beyond ourselves,
like transcendent relating to
something that exists before
humanity was here, not
that humanity is gone,
math as actually practiced
is something we do
because it's something humans wanna do
and we do it for our own reasons.
And I think that's
certainly present in Dove,
but it's also present in
contemporary mathematicians.
Let me quote a wonderful
quote from Bill Thurston,
who I think anyone would say
is one of the great geometers of our time.
Now, unfortunately
deceased a few years back.
He said about math,
"We are not trying to meet
some abstract production quota
of definitions, theorems and proofs.
The measure of our success
is whether what we do
enables people to understand
and think more clearly
and effectively about mathematics."
This is a point that I think is often lost
to people outside of mathematics.
That our job is not, or
what we're interested in
is not what's true or false.
What's interested in,
what we're interested in
is humans increasing their understanding
of what is in the world,
where that might be the physical world,
or it might be the abstract
mathematical world.
David Blackwell, who was a probabilist
like Markov and other
contemporary mathematician,
he put it really bluntly actually.
I think things very close to Thurston.
He said, basically,
I'm not interested in doing
research and I never have been.
Wait, like, imagine that in
your grant proposal, right?
Like we don't say it
in our grant proposal,
but sometimes if we're
being honest, we say it.
I'm not interested in doing
research and I never have been.
I'm interested in understanding,
which is quite a different thing.
And I think it's very clear
that that's what Dove is too.
That Dove correctly
understands that interest
to view what mathematics is about.
You know, so there is
this stereotype I think.
It's what Sylvester
called frozen formality.
That what geometry is about
is locking our intuition
in this straight jacket of rigid proofs.
I think Keats certainly thought that way,
but I think the way that
modern mathematicians
like Thurston and Blackwell
see it is much closer
to what Dove is trying to get at.
Closer to the way I see it if
you want my personal opinion.
That it's about getting to
a point in Dove's words,
that is true and unproven.
Okay, so I'm gonna stop there.
I hope there are some
questions in the chat
'cause I left some time for it.
I will turn off the screen share.
If there's slides that
you wanna see again,
I'm happy to bring them back.
Otherwise you can just look at my face
while I answer your questions.
Thanks everybody for being here.
- Thank you so much.
That was super exciting.
And I would have liked you to
continue almost every story
that you've touched upon.
- You think I wrote a whole book
that you can go to the bookstore and get
that has all these stories in them.
- That's right.
As we wait for people to start
taking stock and type up their questions,
I would like to use this
opportunity to ask my own first.
So I think you've touched upon this
in a lot of your writing.
So there is this question, right?
There's this kind of deep question
about why does mathematics
actually work so well
in describing the world, right?
And in terms of how we should
think about mathematics,
should we think about it
as a system that exists
that we just discover in nature?
I think when I read bits of your book,
I feel like that is sort of, you know,
it's a human endeavor and you,
or do we actually
actively create it, right?
And I think a lot of the
tensions that you talked about,
you know, with geometry and
poetry have to do possibly,
I wonder with this
question of agency, right?
So where mathematics says.
I would love for you,
I would love to hear what
you have to say about that.
- Yeah I mean, it's sort of a very old
philosophical conundrum that
people have wrestled with.
Right, are the truths of mathematics
and the objects of mathematics,
are they discovered or are they invented?
What I like to say is that there
are things that we discover
by inventing them.
- That's a very clever
slip slide through the.
- My clever, of not answering.
But there is some meaning to it.
And maybe what I would say is that,
of course it's a working math pedition.
You cannot help but feel that
the things are just there.
And I think there's no reason,
we have the luxury of not
actually being philosophers.
So it's okay for us to just
like indulge in those feelings.
You know what I mean?
Whether or not those
feelings are correct or not,
there are certainly useful
and usefulness it's what we care about.
You know, maybe I'll throw
a little of psychology
into the mix
because I was just reading
something very interesting
that really resonated with this for me,
I was gonna write a blog entry about it,
but I haven't done it yet.
There is a certain style
of psychotherapy where
they say people think
too much about whether
the way they see the world
is like true or false.
Like there's lots of true
things you can think.
And you only have a very
limited amount of attention.
So the real question is like,
which true things are
you going to think about?
And I think that's very much the,
of math that the question of
which facts are true or false,
you know, I think those are facts,
but the really mathematical
questions is like,
which of those things are we gonna pursue?
Which are we gonna see
is related to each other?
And which as you say, are we gonna use
because of the empirical fact that
these objects that we
think of are inspired by
and then feed back into
telling us stuff about objects
of the natural world, whether
they be planets or poems.
- Great, so I'm waiting, I
see Aaron has raised his hand.
Could you please type
your question in the chat?
- If I may, we do have a comment in.
- Oh please go ahead.
- Just heard about the Poetry Pavilion
by Es Devlin in Dubai.
An address is provided in the chat
and was reminded of this by discussion
about relationships between
consonants and vowels.
Have you heard of this poet Jordan?
- No, so I didn't,
they said the poetry
pavilion or they named a poet
who, I don't know?
- Es Devlin is the poet.
- Oh, okay, no, that's not a poem,
it's not a poet I know actually.
And I certainly, I mean,
please understand that my,
what I know a lot about is math
and what I know a little bit
about his poetry, so I mean, I
of course sort of tend to
like lean on my favorite
if there's As berry in the book too,
but there's many more poets
I don't know anything about
than those I do.
So in particular, if there's people,
there's probably people in the audience,
who know, Wordsworth and
Keats better than I do.
So I hope I've like accurately rendered
this tiny part of their views,
but I'm sure there's
other stuff in their work
that would be enlightening
about this stuff too,
that I just don't know.
- Okay, yeah, any other
questions that are showing up?
- I've checked that chat is
enabled now, so it should be,
might not have been before.
So I might question in.
Okay, it's up now.
- Yeah, sorry about that everyone.
We didn't realize that
the chat was disabled
and as we wait, you know, I was,
oh I have so many
questions but it's not fair
if I keep asking all my questions,
but hey, while we wait.
- Ask a really bad one
and the people in the chat would be like
I can do better than that.
- That's right.
- That's the level of
questions we're getting.
- It's not possible to ask a bad question
because of all this wonderful
stuff that you have.
So I was reading about,
you know, you've also talked in shape
about mathematical concepts,
not just the words,
but the actual concepts
impacting other things like art
and that if you wanted to
see, you could see the inputs,
you could really kind of map out.
And I love the example where
you talk about the, you know,
Geoffrey Hinton and then
you'll talk about, you know,
Hinton's, great-grandfather
Charles who wrote a book.
And then this phrase
Tesseract that, you know,
he invented that word and that, you know,
that you could see this in
Dandi's painting in crucifixion.
So I was just curious,
Jordan, with your frame,
when you walk around
and you look at things,
are you, I mean,
does the mathematical
abstraction always capture you?
Because it seems to me
that you have such a
deep love for mathematics that
you see it everywhere, right?
And it is everywhere
and that's what you're
pointing out to us in shape.
- Yeah, I think so.
I mean, I think, you know,
when you inhabit a certain
landscape for, you know,
several decades as I have,
you're very attuned to
what reminds you of that.
So it's definitely true.
I mean, that's, in some sense,
my process of book
writing is that you know,
a long time happens in between books
and over the course of that time,
like I'm just encountering things
like things in the news,
like things in art or
literature or whatever.
And you know, when it reminds
me of math in some way,
I kind of have a little file
and like I write it down
and I create stuff and I tend
to trust my own instincts.
Like if I'm writing stuff down together,
it must be something that has in common.
And then I've got to
sort of see what it is.
And so, you know, for this book,
I think certainly one thing
that happened is I was like,
I had not been very much of it.
And then we had a giant
pandemic and of course,
like everybody else,
I was sort of spending a lot
of time thinking about that
and trying to get my head around it
and trying to understand it.
And everybody wanted to feel useful.
Like everybody wanted to feel like
the stuff that they knew about
was in some way relevant.
So of course I was trying to think about
what it had to do with math.
Like what my meager and
impractical life's expertise
could possibly have to offer.
And so that of course ends
up in the book, right?
So in the end I learned
a lot about, you know,
the history of epidemiology
and the idea of diseases
spreading through space, which
is a very geometric notion.
Of course, everybody saw
that an event that big
everybody's gonna see it
through their own lens
and see a different aspect of it.
But that certainly is
like part of my process.
Oh, I have like.
- Yeah, there are many questions
that have started coming in now.
- I can read one out if you'd like.
- You did it Priya, okay.
- Okay, from Erin,
you mentioned that
geometry is often the thing
that prompts poets to see
beauty liberation, et cetera,
in mathematics.
Do you think that there's a
specific thing about geometry
that does this, or is
it that students only,
or at least first exposure
to proof based math
is through geometry?
- Yeah, awesome question.
And I feel like I sort
of set myself up for it
with those two poems of Rita Dove
where she like cramps on arithmetic
and then there's like,
but geometry is great.
And it's absolutely true
that in a different world
where everything was taught differently,
that experience you had with geometry,
she could have had with arithmetic
and the theory of numbers
like that certainly could have happened.
In our world, there's
this very long tradition
of somehow seeing Euclid's
geometry as primal.
Like the sort of true thing that everyone,
that everything else is kind of like a
slightly, dirty imitation of.
So I think there's something cultural
and probably like Western cultural
that causes people to reach for Euclid
as this figure of purity that causes,
you know, why doesn't Edison
say like only dive fantasy alone
has looked on beauty bear.
You know what I mean?
I mean, dive fantasy is great, but like,
so I think it's culturally bound
and I don't think it's
intrinsic to the subject
and to be frank, the
lines between geometry
and the rest of math are not too firm.
And I think a very
Catholic view in my book
and, you know, honestly, some
people complain about it.
They're like I wanted more triangles.
I frankly feel cheated.
I bought this book
and then there were like
stuff about Markov chains
and stuff about, you know,
legislative districting
and like all kinds of stuff that like,
it's true I have a very
broad view of what counts as,
as geometric.
- So there's another question, you know,
how can geometry help in the
fight against gerrymandering?
- Great question.
And I write a lot about it in the book
because I live in Wisconsin,
which has some of the most
gerrymandered legislative
districts in the country.
That's how I learned about this stuff
with the help of my colleague, Moon Duchin
mathematician, and a geometer at Tufts,
who's really been on
the front line of this.
Again, I could give a
whole hour on, I often do,
but let me give this sort
of three minute version,
which is to say it
doesn't help by telling us
how to draw congressional district.
It doesn't help by giving
the answer and saying,
what's the right thing to do?
Because that is fundamentally
not a math question.
It has math in it, but
it's a political question.
What it can do,
I always say, it can't tell
you the right way to do it,
but it can tell you about
wrong ways to do it.
It can identify like
really grievous offenses
against fairness and just kind of like
put a fence around the most
egregious gerrymandering
that helps create some space for reform.
And I think, I mean, if you guys,
I don't know how many
people in the audience
are here in the U.S. and
are following U.S. politics,
but this is gonna be a big fight
over the next several months.
It's already happening in some
states, including Wisconsin.
And absolutely there are a
lot of mathematicians who are
providing real time assessments of
the maps that people are drawing
and helping to shine a
light on what's being done.
But I'm not doing it.
I just fight about the people who do it.
- I have another question to read out.
Do you have anything to
say about Lewis Carroll,
the participant and I
agree I've heard this too,
that Alison Wonderland has a lot of
hidden and unhidden mathematics.
- Yes, there's actually like,
you know, in a director's cut,
there's like a deleted scene
where I wrote a bit about
Lewis Carroll because he was
very interested in Euclid
and he had some,
I took this out 'cause I
thought it got a little bit
too into the weeds and
an early part of the book
where I was like writing
about Euclid and his geometry.
But, you know, we have
this stereotype of like,
okay, Euclid, like, that's it perfection
300 AD and it's all been
downhill from there, right?
That's this like, very, like,
it's kind of a bad
cultural habit that we have
of somehow thinking like
everything was perfect in Greece
and then everything since
then is like a sort of like
bad carbon copy of a carbon copy of that.
In fact, Euclid by modern standards,
even though like somebody
like Vincent Millay
would have been told in school,
this is it, the high point of rigor
and beauty and perfection is not rigorous
by modern mathematical standards.
And in fact, the axioms that we talk about
as Euclidean axioms today,
they were cleaned up in
the early 20th century.
We usually use ones,
there's a set by Hilbert.
There's a set by somebody
else whose name escapes me.
They're like, because Euclid
was really not up to the task
of what we now consider rigorous.
So Carroll, he kind of
had a critical essay
where he's like, come on, like
every English school child
learns this proof by Euclid
because it's what Euclid said
and it like makes no sense,
like there's a step that's
completely messed up.
And he's sort of like wrote his own,
which at that time was a sort
of pretty bold thing to do,
but nowadays will be commonplace.
Like everybody knows,
like, yeah, like, I mean,
it's actually, okay.
It's an interesting pedagogical thing
because there are places,
I have a wonderful colleague at St. John's
and we always fight about this.
They learn geometry out of Euclid,
which I think is a terrible mistake.
But I mean, there's a
certain sort of habit of mind
that says like,
well, of course you should
like go to the source,
but that's not what I think.
Euclid's incredibly
historical and important.
I just don't think
that's where you should
learn geometry now.
- Thanks Jordan.
Okay, next question.
Participant says,
I've read your newest book,
Shape and really enjoyed it.
Two-part question from this.
I'm curious what your
favorite mathematics book is
and what other books I should
have on my reading radar.
He knows I also work at a bookshop
and tell every customer about your book.
He's also pursuing his bachelor's
in applied mathematics.
- Everything you do I love.
I love that you're selling my book,
I love that you're studying math.
I can't say that I have a single favorite.
I'll say that
one it's very inspirational
to me as a writer.
And I don't even know if
most people would consider it
a math book.
Is the book Godel Escher
Bach by Douglas Hofstadter.
It's an old book.
I read it when I was a kid,
probably about 50 times.
And you know, when I was a younger kid,
I really didn't understand very much of it
and I skipped a lot of it
and just like each time I would read it,
I would understand more.
But I think if you know the book
it's kind of this meditation
on like ideas of self-reference
and ideas of recursion,
and it kind of ties
together like mathematics,
theoretical computer science,
artificial intelligence,
music, and art, and nobody
else was doing that.
Nobody else was doing anything like that.
And I just found it so inspiring
that you were allowed to do that,
that you were allowed to be
like, not just like physics,
like math touches everything
and just to go his playfulness
and his willingness to sort of
be extremely serious, but not stuffy,
that's kind of a model for me.
If you looked at the,
but I don't know if you
would think his style
was like my style,
but it sort of inspirational to me.
To be quite honest, the
other, I mean, yeah,
no, I think that's, that's as
good an answer as I can give.
I mean, there's a lot of, we're
in a, sort of a golden age
of popular math writing and
like tons of great stuff out
Steve Strogatz's books are all great.
Those are like ones that come to mind.
- He's spoken in our series before.
- Oh, okay.
Why do you ask him first?
No, I'm just kidding.
He's older than me.
- Well, I think is this
is when his book came out.
- Oh, yeah okay.
- We tend to invite people soon after,
as soon as after we can get
them when their books come out.
Okay, so there's a question
from one of our Frankie
fellows that I'll read out.
Before Wordsworth and Keats James Thompson
and Alexander Pope were
famously sparring inverse
over the poetic value of Newtonian optics
and enlightenment sense more generally
a science more generally.
From the early 20th century
into the present day,
countless writers have
registered conflicting feelings
about Einsteinian space-time geometry.
A system at once of staggering beauty
and almost unthinkable
destructive potential.
As we continue to debate the
social responsibility entailed,
for example, an epidemiology models
or mathematical climate models,
are we rehashing the same old debate
as the one you highlight
between Keats and Wordsworth,
or do you notice any interesting shifts
across the historical record,
around the complicated position
of maths and science in culture?
- It's a great question
partly because I'm learning a lot from it.
I hope I don't get like fired
from Frankie for saying this,
but I don't even know
who James Thompson is.
I know who Alexander Pope is.
So as you see,
I have like a somewhat limited view
and don't know about this sparring.
In fact, I strongly encourage you
if you're willing to like email me
and sort of tell me
where I should read about
Thompson and Pope,
because I know there's
like a large history
of which I know only a part,
but to the question, to the question,
I don't think I see that exact
Keats, Wordsworth division
when it comes to things like
climate models for instance,
because I don't think there's like
anyone who takes the stance that,
oh, we're just not fully capturing
like the glorious richness of the climate
by reducing it to questions about
what the average global temperature is.
Right, man, I mean, you could certainly
find people saying that that's productive,
but I think everybody grasps
that that's an important
number that captures
an important feature and is
not like missing the point.
That's what I would take to be the kind of
cutesy and view, right?
If there was sort of somebody
out there who was like,
oh, all these people are like
doing all these hardcore
numerical analysis models
of the climate, like, why
can't they just like, sort of
sit and enjoy like the waves,
like coming down the street
or something like that?
Right, that's not a view.
I think that is like, well,
maybe I'm being too specific,
but here's where I,
okay, let me take it
a different direction.
The place where I think maybe I see it
is in these questions people ask
about the algorithmised self.
Like people who are like, okay,
does like Facebook know me and my friends
better than we know ourselves?
Right, does the algorithm
that sort of can track
your internet usage,
does it have some kind of insight into you
that is in some sense
deeper or at least different
than what humans have?
Yeah, so actually I think that's
the place where you see it,
that, and the sort of similar
question of like what,
you know, what's happening
with machine learning
and what's happening with AI.
Like if we sort of say like,
and I do write about this
in the book, like, you know,
if an AI plays chess very
well, which indeed it does,
is that ruining chest the
way Keats accused Newton
of ruining the rainbow or
does that enrich chess?
And that is the sort of
hotly contested question,
certainly among chess people.
Is that an okay answer?
Do you feel like Tyler,
do you feel like I answered
the question you were asking?
But I took it away from the
things of real political import
epidemiology and climate.
So maybe it's not the direction
you wanted to go with it.
- Let me wait and see
what Tyler has to say.
- Okay, I got some word for this,
but please do write me
about Pope and Thompson
'cause I would love to know.
- So are there any more questions?
Did we, Ty, did you take a look?
We didn't miss any comments or questions.
- I looked, I didn't see any other.
- Well, let's just wait
for another minute or so
to see if there are any final questions,
but Jordan this was absolutely fantastic.
And thank you so much
for this wonderful talk
and I so wish you could have
been here in person, but.
- I'll come another time.
I love that you have a
center for this, by the way.
I wish we had a center for the
science and the humanities,
like what a wonderful concept.
- Yeah, and we would love to invite you
and have you come visit in person.
So let's all thank Jordan
for an excellent talk
for sharing his wonderful insights,
across many, many disciplines
and for getting us all very excited
about new ways to think about mathematics.
Thank you so much.
Thanks everyone for attending.
I just want to close
with our upcoming events
in the Frankie program.
We have a book talk,
another distinguished
speaker series book talk
by Hazel Carby and we
have a talk coming up
by Mariano Sigman, the
neuroscientist on December 8th
and Hazel's talk is on November 3rd.
So I really look forward
to seeing you all.
And I also remind you to come and attend
our monthly inference colloquium series.
Thanks everyone and bye.